sur le secrétaire d'état la parole et à
madame claudine schmidt pour les
républicains
merci madame la présidente mais c'est le
premier ministre jan compterait ses mots
à benjamin franklin en ce monde
rien n'est certain à part la mort et les
taxes les français sont excédés il
attend de vous une réponse claire et
immédiate à l'insécurité économique qui
règne désormais dans notre pays la
france en font chaque jour dans le
marasme de plus en plus profond les
français sont en colère ils se font
entendre
je constate que malheureusement la
france est en tête du palmarès des pays
aux apo les plus élevés selon l' ocde
chez nos voisins les finances publiques
sont plus saines les entreprises
retrouvent d'âge de 29
le chômage baisse françois hollande ne
cesse de marteler que les impôts
n'augmenteraient plus mais c'est sans
parler des taxes qui elle augmente
je prends par exemple le projet de loi
de finances rectificatif pour 2015 qui
accroît la fiscalité écologique
nous sommes favorables à cette fiscalité
pour autant que d'autres taxes baisse
aujourd'hui les français attendent que
votre gouvernement en finisse avec le
matraquage fiscal
à défaut de faire baisser le chômage
faute de quoi l'état puis seront encore
plus dans leur bas de laine
s'ils n'ont pas déjà quitté le pays
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
est double quand prendrez-vous en compte
les propositions fiscales de
l'opposition comme vous venait enfin de
le faire pour les propositions fisc de
sécurité et quand allez vous réagir face
à cette urgence fiscale
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
la volute annoncé le secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
madame je pense que vous n'êtes pas
forcément très bien informé parce que
lorsque sur les différentes questions
que vous abordez vous devriez avoir noté
néanmoins que le pacte de responsabilité
mis en oeuvre depuis maintenant depuis
18 mois par le président de la
république et le gouvernement
mon permis justement d'alléger très
substantiellement les prélèvements qui
peuvent exister sur les entreprises
et cette baisse de charge fait
aujourd'hui que par exemple le coût du
travail français parfaitement compétitif
avec le coût du travail allemand est
donc cette politique nous la menons nous
avons des annonces elles ont été
vérifiées budget après budget mais nous
entendons vous avez essayé de cité
madame la députée les propositions ou
les aspirations de l'opposition pour
autant nous ne savons rien véritablement
chaque mercredi ou mardi aux questions
d'actualité
nous voyons un certain nombre de vos
collègues qui viennent nous demander
plus de dépenses et nous ne savons
toujours pas où est ce que vous allez
baisser le niveau de ses dépenses
publiques qui permettrait éventuellement
qui permettrait éventuellement de
baisser la fiscalité alors je crois
qu'au delà
au delà des déclarations d'intention aux
lames la députée il serait tout à fait
utile que l'opposition fasse ce travail
de clarification sur le sujet de la
fiscalité sur le sujet du budget comme
de la même façon elle pourrait le faire
aussi sur sa stratégie politique et
d'ailleurs il me semble les français
vous ont dit ces derniers jours que
peut-être la position qui était la vôtre
n'était pas si clair qu'elle manquait un
petit peu de précision et que au
contraire ce gouvernement prenez lui sa
responsabilité